the Joe Rogan experience let me touch on
the Dan Bilzerian think I heard is he
coming here on in May is that right on
the pot yes nothing I know okay someone
had said to me oh I hear Dan bells he's
gone before though yeah I know he has I
thought that was coming out soon it kind
of made me nervous cuz so I a couple
weeks ago Whitney's like just just drill
and Danville's Aryan on Instagram for
having this polar bear right there's
video of a polar bear to [ __ ] party
and he's feeding it she's just she's
right apart
yeah I was like a big there's a big
brown bear like grizzly was a big
grizzly bear morally yeah on a you know
the electric fence around everything
else so she was he probably one of his
Chris house yeah oh Jesus Dan Bilzerian
what the [ __ ] bro oh my god he had a
[ __ ] brown bear at his house look at
the size of that thing oh my god I'm
getting anxiety did he ever see the
[ __ ] what was the yeah yeah yeah the
one where the bear ripped a guy's throat
apart that was one in a movie to us
no the bear was in a movie the bear was
in a football movie what was that movie
let's go on with a basketball I think
he's been in a few movies but with Will
Ferrell where there's playing basketball
any like wrestled him in the middle of
the basketball game was that the bear
yeah I think so
well there was a bear that had been in
movies and had done stunts in movies and
this guy video was awful because the guy
is literally just standing there and the
bear just goes up to them and just
decides to attack and rips his throat
out in a second it's exactly that video
- the this yeah it can happen at any
freakin time only you got 45 girls in
the back scantily clad it easily could
happen you know what's really crazy is
that that bear that killed that guy they
went back to training them they're not
gonna kill an animal that has value it's
the same as the Orca that killed all the
trainers they could they're not gonna
kill him it's just not gonna happen but
they were trying to like figure out
whether or not he was gonna do it again
like Jesus Christ what do you have
soothsayer how are you gonna figure out
what a bear is gonna do it's gonna be a
bear [ __ ] there's gonna be better air
stuff the people that are bringing that
are trying to get have you interact with
these animals like that they're they're
they're relying on the animals shock
factor the shock and awe you know
they're bringing these animals in the
close proximity to scare you
that's a [ __ ] up thing man that's the
bear right there look at that I said
throw it apart so so horrific so back to
the the Whitney thing so Whitney's just
just harping on Danville's and he's
deleting the comets as quick as she's
tossing so I decided okay well I'm gonna
weigh in now right so I throw a comment
and I forget about I turn to go off do
my thing and then that night I'm on the
Phil DeFranco show not me personally but
he actually takes the comment because
they know he got a lot of likes and
stuff I said something to the effect of
you know that's an abuse then I'm all
blah blah blah it's not I said something
you know smoke more weed they put the
comment up oh by the way the guy who
handles the animal he was sort of he was
using some legal sort of jargon with me
as if he's maybe was talking about
lawsuit nice - [ __ ] it sue me legal
jargon - the guy who's a Natori because
I said that's a starved abused animal I
mean I know how do you I know how in the
history of wild animals when is a bear
ever walked out and said hey I'm gonna
become [ __ ] friends with someone today
you know [ __ ] this well guard them out
when there are little Cubs you know that
of course
so they starve them they abuse them they
have them I mean but do they have to do
that to train them I know there are
people who claim to love bears that
train bears to take care of bears and I
guarantee you they don't all do that it
says big no-no there's nothing fun about
abusing a drugged starved animal delete
this and your penchant for animal
exploitation smoke more weed
I don't know smoke more weed just like
gonna help that but it wasn't a chirp
that when do we fill the Franco said it
was like I was like smoke more weed you
fool I was just like no no smoke more
weed like go inside what I think okay
got it no yeah it see I feel like there
are people that have bears that raise
them and I'm not in any way shape or
form endorsing keeping bears in
captivity but what I see is people that
have these sort of intimate
relationships with these really well-fed
bears they're big and happy and they
feed them and they're getting the pool
with them and it's it looks ridiculous
but I don't think they're starving that
bear I don't think they're abusing that
bear and I don't think you have to do
that I don't think you couldn't
automatically assume that a bear is
starved and abused so I assume the
starved part I certainly can't say but
it's a big bear those a fat bear nice
feeding it might be hungry that
I mean it's more than saying we'll look
at the body on the bear Oh big nice
well-fed bear you can have a well-fed
animal that's hungry for a week there's
no question about that but it's not
likely that that thing star and my
definition of abuse is there's an
electric fence around that [ __ ] thing
which is that yeah you can see it about
the ankle ankle there's a [ __ ]
electric fence it yeah house well I'm
sure whoever so back to that pic I'm
sure whatever installation this the the
person who brought this thing does has
to keep the animal within the confines
of imagine it was just went on a model
killing rampage like that's an electric
I that's again an assumption I'll say
but again I don't see how that wouldn't
be what the hell does that serve as a
barrier it's just a trip line otherwise
for it that is so and so that's a
well-fed bear though son look at that
thing that mother [ __ ] eats that is a
big ass if you want to get an animal to
do something if you want it to be docile
you have to train it you have to sort of
there's breaking the animal in many
cases but I'll assure you Joe that food
deprivation is in training is your most
effective tool it just is you can find a
healthy balance right but food
deprivation is we've not won you've
talked about this particularly with
dolphins to be fair in my my experience
of wild animals it is with marine
mammals so yeah not worked with bears
there are bears at Marineland it's a
really it's a disgusting display it's an
archaic it looks like it's out of the
eighteen hundreds even I mean it really
is a disgusting place but the practice
was to starve them mm-hmm and what
people do there is they pay like I think
it's a buck and they get like this this
is a little cup full of corn pops and
you the Bears are like waving yeah
historically there's been bears I mean
he's got they've got like 40 or 50 bears
in this little confined space I mean
there's nothing there's no more no
greater abomination of nature than I can
imagine than a solitary largely solitary
animals are they confined to a bunch of
them of the speed and then historically
they have ripped each other apart and
though I can actually delve into marine
lands history deeper than I can you get
to hear the full spectrum of some of the
things that happened and bear in mind
and it's important to note it was a
different time different times different
things happen and that's just that was
the that was that was the norm it's it's
you know starkly contrasting time to
when marine lines
darn it so but the stories are like
really it's jaw-dropping
it's really jaw-dropping stuff but
[Applause]